ciao a tutti comunque trovo alcuna
pubblicità siano veramente belle belle
creare e dare forma al proprio destino
non si è mai troppo lontani per poi
ritrovarsi al sangue anni più o meno
dire sappiamo mai pentirsi non ciò che
si è fatto perché quando lo si è fatto
lo si era felice ciao
ieri mio nonno e mio padre
domani che ai figli non smetteranno di
sognare
basta per il contadino gennarino
l'amore per il tuo proposto cosa basta
contadino generi na l'amore per il tutto
allora no semi di vendere un piatto di
pasta nomi sempre che tu parta dalla
botte come si procacciarsi cibo nel
cenozoico di indirettamente completa in
che poi pasta gennaro e poi nutriente
non scuoce mai
ecco la verità anche se la lontra delle
facoltà
no perché spesso le pubblicità non è che
c'entrino molto con quello che devono
venderti no che era un sogno da grande
vuol diventare una di quelle
ricercatrici che fanno sempre tenerezza
in questo tipo di pubblicità noi
naturalmente per non saper né leggere né
scrivere
non sappiamo se chiaro e riuscirà a
farcela tu però nel frattempo a botta
per bene di merendine e poi ci sono le
mie preferite in assoluto quelle dei
profumi sigla
[Musica]
insomma
voglio sedermi in un bilancio di otto
remo stazzo ragazzi almeno fatemelo
sapere perché non lo so a voi veramente
fanno vivi voglia di comprare delle cose
che sponsorizzano quali sono invece
pubblicità che vi fanno venir voglia di
comprare tutto quello che vi fanno
vedere e poi non sono molto meglio le
televendite fatemelo sapere un commento
qui sotto in un video risposta
chi era cambiato sogno che adesso spera
di diventare una modella di fama
internazionale chiama la scema noi
naturalmente come prima non sappiamo se
riuscirà a farcela però ecco lasciati
dare un consiglio
smettila di adottarla di merendine
[Musica]